[Música]
quase como uma certa evidência assim vou
adivinhar aqui nesse momento que todos
vocês
a primeira experiência musical que vocês
tiveram na vida foi a mãe de vocês
cantando canções de ninar maravilhosa né
realizei aqui uma super vidência na
verdade não na verdade a gente sabe
muito bem que a gente ouve na barriga da
mãe ou fora externamente
às vezes tem mais até que criam canções
para os filhos e no fim das contas
muitas vezes ali na infância com canções
infantis para brincar que a gente vai
perpetuando essas canções e esta
perpetuação de canções é tão importante
que foi o nosso folclore que a gente
chama é inclusive de identidade cultural
repertório que faz ali a gente que o
pessoal do acre sabe as mesmas canções
infantis
ele sabe tudo bem mas o que a gente
talvez não nunca tinha parado para
pensar é quando a gente vai aprender
esse repertório folclórico de outras
canções canções de trabalho
a gente não pára pra pensar que muitas
vezes elas são canções de trabalho das
ladeiras das cozinheiras criações
coletivas
até agora a gente só fala de mulheres
bem e essa noção de identidade e
folclore que é tão importante a gente
pode falar não mas vai até o folclore
tudo isso para dizer o seguinte eu tenho
uma família realizadora de dois poetas e
compositores é mais ou menos como se a
filha do dn jn e dn que se resolvesse
roqueira oitava e ainda chamando estar o
nome que não é nem comum e que vem
sempre uma pergunta depois seu nome
mesmo seu filho do paulo leminski e
alice ruiz
entre uma pergunta e depois e nesse
processo eu falei bom então o seguinte
que me resta o atrás vai estudar
eu quero entender esse negócio como é
que funciona a faculdade e comecei a
descobrir coisas impressionantes estudar
sobre a identidade cultural brasileira o
ritmo mais conhecido nosso que o brasil
e que o brasil não muito inteiro conhece
a gente pelo samba ea gente conhece a
história do samba mais ou menos o
seguinte vocês ouviram essa história vai
ser meio parecida
o samba nasceu na casa da tia ciata
legal bacana o pessoal de lá aí continua
aí inclusive ata foi muito importante a
tia ciata levou o samba da bahia para o
rio de janeiro
gente eu sou muito esse ano eu pensava
assim o celta foi na mala o samba era
cozinheira também ela sabia fazer
brigadeiros com cobertura de samba e
achava muito estranho isso porque eu
pensava bom faz sentido na minha
dinâmica aqui decomposição e do que tudo
que eu estudei
geralmente quem leve que perpetua e
ensina os outros a fazer uma coisa quem
faz a coisa certa e aí descobrir uma
coisa muito impressionante a gente
atribui todo o início do samba todos os
sambistas e esses sambistas aprenderam
com a tia ciata a tia ciata era
compositora e todos os funcionários
músicas representada apenas como
agitadora cultural mãe de santo e
cozinheiro
o mário de andrade em contraponto diz
assim numa lata regional jacy ato é
sempre vista com seu violão no colo e
dizem as más línguas que os seus sons
mais fechados são surrupiados por muitas
pessoas que freqüentam a casa dela está
lá nos anos 20 ea gente tem a cultura
inclusive do control c control v ea
gente podia muito bem se aprofundar
mas a gente ainda vai me pede e perpetua
certos
rio é fogo bom vamos lá vamos lá pra
identidade cultural dos estados unidos o
rock a kibon viva elvis presley olhos
presley
ele era aquele moleque que ia correndo
literalmente de casa para ouvir o
programa de rádio da rosetta tharpe
rosetta tharpe guitarrista que mesmo
mesclou elementos de blues e começou a
cantar daquele jeito que inspirou tanto
o elvis presley enquanto pequim enquanto
bob dylan quando a rosetta tharpe parece
que quase nunca é chamada não é piada
tia avó do rock
tudo isso para dizer se juntar com o
fato de que eu fui pra faculdade para
descobrir que não adiantava
absolutamente nada eu sou uma boa pessoa
o que eu queria fazer para ser o
compositor é um simples fato de não
adianta realizar se você invisível certo
então voltando lá naquele momento que a
gente estava no no berço ali no colo da
nossa mãe e ela cantando pra gente até a
gente fechar o olho e adormecer
eu comecei a pensar como que como esse
processo é tão cruel e como é que ele
funcionava e eu entendi o seguinte ele
vem é de uma de uma certa inclusive um
período em que se uma mulher pública era
muito uma coisa muito mal visto
inclusive a chiquinha gonzaga que é a
criadora da primeira gravadora
independente do país sofreu muito com
isso
então a gente até pode entender que às
vezes elas inclusive falava melhor nem
saberem que o compõem
waking mas aí já é enfim depois de tanto
tempo a gente falou identidade falou da
história a gente continuar perpetuando
as suas questões ea gente vive na
verdade um outro momento momento
inclusive depois desse período onde a
mulher não podia ter trabalhos públicos
a gente já teve o boom das grandes
gravadoras o star system michael jackson
grandes bandas bitos e etc isso fiquei
pensando e muitas vezes assim o
contraponto que é com esse início é como
o nosso início também é uma experiência
inicial de de de música na nossa vida
que forma nosso repertório que forma as
nossas melodias e na faculdade acontecia
o mesmo tinha maioria da minha sala eram
de meninas elas inclusive tinha passado
na frente da maioria dos meninos mas
quando tinha uma banda cê formada na
faculdade
os meninos que eram chamados
olha o que a gente pode fazer aqui mas
ao mesmo tempo estava num outro balaio
que o problema o buraco é mais embaixo
a gente já tava numa virada tão início
do boom da internet junto com a música
com a indústria musical e à música
independente àquela da chiquinha gonzaga
foi só uma gravadora agora é uma coisa
que a gente mal consegue dimensionar
quantos braços têm quantas formas a
gente tem pra fazer música inclusive
pessoas que estão nessas no sistema de
gravadoras e grandes empresários muitas
vezes já têm noção aquele cara que era
só genial e não precisa se preocupar com
absolutamente nada
onde ele vai fazer show com que roupa
vai investir onde ele tem que tá que
horas ele tem que acordar esse cara não
existe mais hoje minimamente enfatiza
tem que saber o que está acontecendo e
aí junto com a música independente
o artista se muda um pouco de figura
transfigurar um pouquinho e ele virou um
cara chamado auto produtor don hahn
produtor tem uma característica muito
maluca gente ele é um ser misto híbrido
porque ele é o produtor e esse produtor
pode ser um pouco empresário pouco
office boy um pouco a gente um pouco
estilista um pouco artista visual um
pouco
todas as coisas que a gente inclusive
hoje viu entanto os tedx e ver tantos
estudos e geralmente tem é uma pessoa
que é multifunção e consegue ter atenção
simultânea para tantas coisas homens as
mulheres as mulheres
e aí a gente é assim tão bacana estrela
nesse momento se falou agora vai dar
certo final feliz
termino com uma grande imagem aqui no
slide deus sendo feliz maravilhosa com a
platéia com mais de mil pessoas e online
de um festival só de mulheres não gente
não tem esse final feliz desculpa tem
uma outra questão que é muito importante
que a gente tenha assim a gente fala 80
metros duas mulheres ajudam visibilidade
bacana que ótimo
o problema é que a gente associa à
internet também uma coisa temporal
passageira
isso faz muitas vezes com que a gente
olhe e fale em uma matéria sobre
mulheres e falhe a vez delas ou avós
bisavós como se tivesse surgido agora
surgindo agora e ainda por cima tem até
um outro detalhe que é um detalhe
lingüístico que já não bastasse a gente
no plural sempre se masculinizar estamos
a 300 mulheres e um homem
a gente e ela sentirá eles têm uma outra
questão é um vício de linguagem quase a
gente chamar as compositoras de cantoras
se você pesquisar no google fez
experiência para montar o sped e é
impressionante você tem lá 39 milhões de
verbetes pra compositor e 36 milhões
para cantoras
ou seja ao vício de linguagem quando
você de chamar muita gente chama também
compositor e cantor
dificilmente ele vai chamar o copo de
irlan pessoas que não tem não tem uma
excelência vocal a gente não chama de
cantor
o problema da gente chamar as cantoras
compositoras e cantoras
muitas vezes eu ouço pessoas falam mas
eu não gosto muito trabalho falando
a voz dela gente vamos combinar
amo muito trabalho de bob dylan mas não
foi pela excelência vocal que a gente
vai se apaixonar o trabalho dele é ou
não é
então é um pouco de visibilidade da
realização das mulheres e um pouco
é também de uma eu tenho inveja a gente
fala uma palavra que tem conta de tanta
diversidade cultural que a gente tem e
eu realmente tenho inveja do espanhol
que tem o cantautor e dá conta disso
maravilhosamente cantor e cantora então
é era para ser um final feliz mas na
internet tem todas essas questões é
rápido a hype é moda é meme é trend
topics
então estamos num momento de chegar e
ver iniciativas maravilhosas as mulheres
mas não adianta a gente vê essas
iniciativas falar ah agora sim a gente
vai aqui ó dá espaço
então meu convite diferente gente não é
pra ninguém dá espaço do mesmo jeito que
no início de tudo a gente estava ali
para fechar os olhos com música meu
convite pra vocês abrirem os olhos e
compositoras estão bem na nossa frente
obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]